الجمل مخلوق لا يصدق
من حيث كيفية تطوره على مر
السنين من حيث أنه في
حيوانات قوية جدًا ، لذا فهي لا تظهر لنا
بالضرورة نقاط الضعف أو لا
تظهر لنا علامات المرض حتى
نهاية
واحدة من  التحديات التي نواجهها في
ذلك بحلول الوقت الذي يأتون إلينا فيه
يمكن أن يكونوا مرضى للغاية لدرجة أنه بغض النظر عما نفعله
لا يمكننا دائمًا تحقيق نتيجة إيجابية
، يأتي مسدس خشبي على كبير
لحن جيد قليلاً ، أنا شكل مقياس الحرارة
إنها المرأة  لا توجد حرارة ، قام Phil Adam
بقتل البحث عن النبيذ الذي نجري
عددًا كبيرًا من الأنواع المختلفة من
الإجراءات الجراحية ، وبعضها
لم يقسمها إلى
إجراءات اختيارية ، ثم أيضًا في
إجراءات الصدمات الطارئة ، دعنا نقول ذلك
بالنسبة للإجراءات الاختيارية التي نحصل عليها.
أي شيء من الإزالة الجماعية البسيطة على
سبيل المثال إلى شيء يتعلق
بالرأس والأسنان أو الإصابات الرضحية
قد تكون مرتبطة بعد ذلك بالإصابات التي
تحدث ثانوية لحوادث بعض
هذه الحوادث.  على سبيل المثال ، يحدث
على المسار الصحيح فيما يتعلق بإعداد الجمل
للجراحة ، إنه مشابه جدًا للطريقة التي
نعد بها الإنسان بالفعل
لعملية جراحية أو أي حيوان آخر ، لذلك
نقوم عادةً بفحص عام ونقوم
بعملنا التشخيصي ونقوم بإجراء الفحص
بعد ذلك  سيبقى الجمل في
المستشفى طوال الليل في صباح يوم
الجراحة ، وسوف يأتي الجمل إلى
منطقة التحضير ، ثم نقوم
بتخدير الجمل
، ثم نعطي الجمل
دواءه التعريفي ، ثم
ندير الجمل على جانبه في مكانه المتعرج
حوله.  ساق الإبل ورفع
الجمل في الهواء بحيث يكون الجمل في
الواقع مقلوبًا في تلك المرحلة ،
ثم سننقل الجمل من
منطقة التحضير إلى منطقة الجراحة
، وبعد ذلك سيخضع الجمل
للتحضير الأولي للجانب الجراحي.
سنقوم بعمل فرك جراحي كامل ثم
نجهز الجدول وبعد ذلك سنمضي
قدمًا ونقوم
بإجراء عملية جراحية أعتقد أن المهم جدًا
بالنسبة لنا هو التأكد من أن
ما نحن عليه  إن القيام بذلك هنا هو في المقام الأول
تحسين رفاهية الإبل
وهذا في حد ذاته يمثل تحديًا كبيرًا
لأن كل إجراء نقوم به له
تأثير على ذلك الجمل ، ونأمل أن
نتمكن من الاستمرار في تحسين وتطوير
التقنيات المختلفة لجعل
حياة الإبل  من دبي وفي
البلدان الأخرى بأقصى قدر ممكن من الراحة
[موسيقى]
لك